auf jeden fall falls du das siehst danke
an dich das ist richtig cool
servus sg zh und ganz sich willkommen zu
einer 64er runde zwei games wir werden
hier ganz entspannt man runde zocken und
nicht weil ich ein bisschen wasser
zebras was mich heute beschäftigt und
zwar ist die zeit gekommen um wieder
abschied zu nehmen von meiner familie so
leid es mir tut online facti die
experten ist leider ja ich fahre heute
wieder zurück zu in meinem einen
studienort in meine wg und ja muss jetzt
meinen bruder krankenhaus macht muss
jetzt verabschieden meine familie auch
und ja dann wieder runter fahren
sozusagen und ich habe alles schon
gepackt das auto ist schon voll
ich mache jetzt noch schnell dieses
video damit etwas zu sehen hab damit ihr
euch nicht langweilen ist nur weil ich
nach hause fahre und dann geht's auch
schon direkt los ich glaube wir gehen
wir links hoch zu diesem hangar
vorangekommen mal schauen ob der fall
weil wir jetzt ab die eine oder andere
projekt eine gute waffe und der
wahrscheinlichen team mit dem anderen es
aussieht hmm 64er sg ist einfach so
voller teams es ist so team verseucht
ich habe jetzt auch gerade so eine 64er
runde von stegen gesehen
one man army wie ist wieder da oder so
und ja da erzählt darum ist er genau das
gleiche und regt sich da auch bisschen
über teams auf und ja also ich kann es
gut nachvollziehen weil ich sagen
ihr wisst ja ich bin selber einer der
teams überhaupt nicht ab kann und gerade
dann wenn man das schafft nur zwei leute
auf einen drauf gehen ein zu töten
die dann noch irgendwie so lange
hinterher ist man irgendwie gestorben
ist eine lüge minuten lang fünf minuten
lang 6 78 minuten lang fokus
nur weil man ihrem teampartner gekehrt
hat als wärs irgendwas schlimm ist und
nicht eine besondere leistung das
da kann ich so ab da ist ein wesen mit
dem bisschen schon in der tür
weil die auch im team wahrscheinlich
schon
afag mehr leute machen einen kurzen cut
und machen einfach in der 24 runde
weiter würde ich sagen weil sonst das
einfach solange es so lady immer wieder
diesmal eine 24 grunde weil 64er jetzt
bisschen kritisch wird wahrscheinlich
wenn ich jetzt jetzt relativ astra
aufnehmen muss weil es wirklich so viele
teams gibt wenn man einmal pech hat und
einer von 25.000 gegnern ein irgendwie
erwischt von hinten oder keine ahnung
oder im team da ist was einem die ganze
nacht an ist und deswegen denke ich
mache eine 24 erst das so geht was das
was da so geht natürlich der familie zu
haben wieder mehr hinterher läuft hier
oder
alle
123 und dann hier auf den ihr drauf
fertig sind die extras so viel wasser
dafür also für die erste affirmativ wir
haben erst mal da oben herunter
nein ich bin doch kann man so schlecht
sein das gibt es ja nicht runter auch
nicht leute ich hab einfach einfach ein
slot zu weit gestreut und habe einfach
den heiltrank geworfen
statt die angeln auf ihn geworfen wo man
leute das sind die momente wo ich mich
einfach in einem loch vergraben will und
aufhören möchte zu existieren vor allem
wenn es noch wenn der aufwand passiert
wird mir schon so stehen wenn mir das
passiert wenn ich alleine spiele aber
eine aufnahme
das ist echt schon bitter da werde ich
heute nacht schlecht schlafen denke ich
mal
das wird nicht leicht für mich aber
trotzdem versuchen ein bisschen weiter
zu kommen selbst arbeitete ist ja noch
gewesen darum ist die kiste die wollen
wir uns ihr wisst ja das ist meine
standard router da zum bahnhof
arbeitsstand haus hab ich doch gar nicht
besucht jetzt schauen wir doch mal rein
so wie es hier aussieht könnte das auch
noch frei seien rüstungs mäßig schon
einmal hier drüben
und das nicht erst als mäßig dabei will
ich sage und schreibe hier ein frontaler
frontale frontal natürlich der hat jetzt
keine chancen der situation verbessere
rüstung besser waffe und er hat in
leggins sehr gut
das heißt wir sind bis auf den
heimischen volland 61 punkte das blog
bin ich sehr entspannt hier ein wollen
ich ja wahrscheinlich
wir gehen da drüben geht er in chat wenn
die stadt zu suchen müssen wissen ich
habe also direkt neben t natürlich war
noch keiner war ja klar
und deswegen passt jetzt mir manchmal
dass ich einfach nicht verquicke und
hoops berlin flug modus kommen weg mit
jeder zeit
ich hoffe jetzt keine störung und
kleinen sohn der auf jeden fall ein
kenner buch und schon ist das tier
ihr dürft halt einfach ihr dürft wer
muss ich glaube ich nicht sagen das ist
selbsterklärend verletzt auf dem helm
hätten dann bei mir eigentlich entspannt
voll ein
lol ich hab ja ok warum habe ich noch
was
das kann doch nicht sein
oh mein gott bekommen das denn hier habe
ich habe letztens in den kommentaren
gelesen dass einer gesagt hat hier will
oder kann es mein optikern kate haben
hat er mir das jetzt einfach geschenkt
geht das kann man einfach leuten den
optikern cape anziehen weil ich habe
selbst nicht ausgewählt auf jeden fall
falls du das siehst danke an dich das
ist richtig cool das passt perfekt zu
diesem leben stirnband rosenmuster was
denkt nach einem scan drauf hab
geschmacklich sehr gute wahl
du hast auf jedenfalls die kollegen und
vielen vielen dank für das okay von cape
finde ich sehr cool
krass ich kann es gar nicht abwarten wie
das passieren könnte schreibt sie auf
jeden fall mal die kommentare erklärt
mir das mal bitte weil ich will jetzt
doch ein bisschen ratlos so da unten ist
eine ratlose die menschen ohne makel
es sollte auf jeden fall niemals rapper
werden in meinem leben weil doch ich
glaube ich werde gar nicht schlechter
rappern
er haut ab okay er hat noch nicht ganz
raus manier läuft nicht übrigens auch
nicht aber ein bisschen bessere hoffe
ich doch mal nicht okay das war's den
haben wir dann wieder gut erwischt in
der situation wohl nicht abhauen kann
sehr nice und die runde könnte
eigentlich ziemlich genau passenden
jetzt schnell die anderen noch erledigen
vielleicht ohne gewinn werd ich super
entspannt aber weiß ich jetzt gar nicht
ob das so gut das funktioniert hat auf
jeden fall ein hengstfohlen und taten
feuerzeug sehr gut
das gefällt mir
rottweil dass wir das auch an
also hier muss man irgendwie die profis
haben und dich zu laufen
keine ahnung ich habe einfach nicht ich
mache halt auch nie aber okay ich hoffe
natürlich dass marc und ich verfolge
vielleicht von diesem optisch ein cash
das ist ja sooo geil auch mal das ist
echt richtig kugel richtig cool finde
diese optik hat ob die fein caps echt
schädlich weil jetzt haltet euch fest
ich weiß es hat ein bisschen dumm an
aber ich finde irgendwie mann ist kein
kann so kann man es nicht aufziehen ich
habe mich ja nicht selbst verbrauche das
ist das ist falsch
aber ich finde irgendwie jeder der gut
ist in minecraft oder so markus pvp hat
um den optikern cap oder die
allermeisten soll ich bei den meisten
zumindest gesehen deswegen freue ich
mich natürlich jetzt zumindest aus zu
sehen wie einer der bisschen was kann
denn bei craft sehr entspannt und vielen
dank an dich du großzügiger spender
stiller großzügiger spender okay nicht
ganz so stelle ich mir gesagt aber wir
müssen auch einfach ein bisschen
feuerwehr spieler das feuer löschen
das wäre unverantwortlich bitte jetzt
kein team in das match okay ist klein
arena und dass es wohl ein team
es ist wohl ziemlich sicher ein team das
inliner
ok
meinetwegen
ich hab mich nur gewundert wie oft etwa
drei leute wie ist der mission comedy
keine art drei leute auch immer wieder
gesehen ja trotzdem sie war mal gut von
dir hab versucht dich zu verteidigen
konnte natürlich nichts machen aber live
aber eigentlich richtig gute runde
nachdem die 64er runde jetzt so bisschen
verunglückt war
ich hoffe es euch gefallen ihr könnt
gerne einen daumen nach oben da lassen
wir in die kommentare schreiben
mehr von diesen runden hat wahr haben
wollte ich einfach mal so spiele mit dem
thema dabei und einfach ein bisschen
erzählt ein bisschen aus dem nähkästchen
plaudern und ihr könnt euch das sagen
jetzt schon mal demnächst ein neues
projekt fräulein projekt das unter
anderem auch viele viele netze
interessanter bestrafungen beinhalten
wird aber dazu vielleicht demnächst mehr
also haltet die augen offen schaut
regelmäßig vorbei es wird auch richtig
geil und wir sind vom nächsten video